hey what's up guys mkbhd here I asked on
Twitter if you guys wanted it and
resoundingly most of you guys said yes
so found you further ado this is a tour
of what's on my Android phone which at
least right now anyway happens to be the
Galaxy Note 2 let's take a look all
right so the device of choice here is
indeed the Samsung Galaxy Note 2 from
Verizon as you can tell by the branding
everywhere all over this device I'm
putting a sticker on that home button
right after this video is over but
basically it's a big device I know but
it kind of fits me it's a big enough
device that it gives me advantages over
my galaxy s3 previously but I've been
enjoying it so far and basically I'll
start off with the software basically
everything about this is still stuck but
it's running a ton of different apps
that make it seem like it's rooted and
running a version of stock Android but
this is still totally stock and I'll
show you all the apps and everything all
the information you need to know about
this is down right below the like button
on this video in the description so be
sure to hit that up if you want that
information but we're start here with
the lockscreen of course and the lock
screen is called widget Locker and it's
just a simple clock widget here with
widget Locker that I'll get to you in a
second but widget Locker gives me access
to Google now the phone dialer messaging
camera and unlocking and this is the
Nova Launcher prime home screen so
that's right my launcher is Nova
Launcher prime and I don't have actually
more than one home screens just one home
screen everything is really tightly
centralized and gives me quick access to
everything that I do on this device
first of all I'll go ahead and show you
up top here this is super widget pro
that's the most frequently asked
question I get about this set up super
widget pro and it's actually one of the
stock default customizations that you
can get out of the box so you buy the
app you go ahead and add a 4 by 2 widget
or a 5 by 2 widget depending on how bad
your home screen is and you can just add
that with you right there and it's
actually Christmas Eve right now so that
is the date widget super and down here
is HD widgets and this is just a couple
quick shortcuts so I can tap here to get
to my battery and it also tell me how
much battery percentage I have left this
is the tote lock and unlock and that's a
camera light and actually does work as
you can
so that will turn on the LED light on
the back of my device further down here
of course like I said I don't have more
than one home screen but I do have more
than one dock and that's a lot of the
part of how I get to my apps so going
through my dock down here at the bottom
I have the phone dialer I have tasks and
I have my home button here and messages
and Chrome and actually obviously if you
tap the app it will open it up but
actually have a swipe action on messages
to open a new message when I swipe up
from it so that's pretty useful and of
course the others will bring you to
their designated apps and I'll swipe
over to the next page here and there's
Google now when I swipe up from Google
now it takes me to the voice Actions so
that's pretty nifty as well Google+ is
the Google+ app stock of course Falcon
pro is probably the best Twitter app for
Android right now at least it's a really
new one and it's really well well done
very polished and smooth so Falcon pro
for Twitter I use a stock calendar app
from the Google Play Store because it's
so much nicer than the Samsung one and
lastly there is the stock TouchWiz a
camcorder or kind of camera app I have
the shortcut here themed of course but
it's the stock app then there's
Instagram I also use something called
press for Google Reader it's a pretty
good app for reading through your feeds
I haven't sorted into different
categories here and different feeds but
that's how I read through Google Reader
pocket which is where I keep things to
read for later and then I have two
folders here one for music and one for
location so I use Foursquare and Google
Maps a lot and I also use all of these
music apps so SoundHound this was
actually a widget to immediately start
idea whatever it's listening to so it's
quick little shortcut there and also
there's Spotify Google Play Music &
Sound Cloud so those are all the apps
down here in my dots and of course when
I swipe up from home I also get straight
into the Google now app Google now is
awesome I use this more probably than
most people do but it's a really really
useful app I'll go ahead to my
notification tray here and I have a
couple of things in here one is called
swipe pad and swipe pad is basically you
can swipe in from the edge of your
screen and get a number of shortcuts to
apps now I actually swipe in and when I
swipe in it take me to recent tasks and
that's something you can get from the
Play Store as well it's called
Tad's and so you can choose a swipe in
from the left from the bottom left
bottom right top left top right wherever
I choose to swipe from the bottom
because that's the way it kind of works
out for me
also you can of course long press on
home you can still use the stock
TouchWiz way but I prefer this way it's
pretty nifty and it will let you open up
whatever recent apps you were using so
that's nice what else is up here battery
reborn battery widget reborn is one of
the best new apps of 2012 gives you your
battery history here it's telling me I
have 54% battery left and it will give
me all sorts of information about how
much battery I've been using so it's a
really good app and I have the pro
version of that as well I tend to pay
for apps if they're good so if it's good
enough I will pay for it and of course
Google Plus is in here too so that's the
basics of my Android setup here on my
galaxy note 2 I can take you through the
app drawer just for a little bit just to
show you what else I have installed I
have a lot of apps from the Play Store
that are like stock Android apps so for
example the stock calculator you can get
that from the Android Play Store clock
jb+
is basically the stock Android 4.2 jelly
bean clock app you can get that from the
Play Store this is the stock contacts
when I was Google Drive Dropbox I am the
sky is my weather app I was also asked
about this I posted a screenshot about
how it was going to snow on Christmas
this is weather sorry I in the sky which
is the weather app that I use it's
pretty good I use it a lot more clouds
than Sun that's nice to know it's also
cold and what else gallery ICS is
basically what I use to go through the
gallery because the stamps on gallery is
not very good so this is the basically
the gallery that I use to look through
the pictures that I take with the note
twos impressive camera what else is
there a Geekbench Falcon pro like I said
next page mint package buddy really good
app also for tracking packages and it
can sync over multiple devices so if you
have like a tablet you can install
package buddy on the tablet and it'll
track all the packages you have all
punched into your phone already Need for
Speed Most Wanted is pretty great I play
that probably more than I should anyway
reddit news is the reddit app that I use
so for those of you who read it check
this one out it's pretty good I still
have the stock Google Reader app but
I'll probably delete that soon score
Center s note which I do occasionally
use off without the stylus here just
because I can finish this video with the
stylus what else is there
oh this is a screenshot or did I just
freeze it now alright s note I use
occasionally Snapseed is also pretty
good it's from Google and you can use it
to edit photos it's not like that useful
to me because I don't edit photos on my
phone that often but whenever you want
to it's there then there's SoundHound
for identifying songs that are playing
SoundCloud for listening songs Spotify I
use Spotify pretty much exclusively for
my music and app syncs with Facebook so
if you subscribe to me on Facebook you
see all the music that I listen to on
Spotify and that's basically a Google
Tasks and YouTube I'll go ahead and open
the YouTube app just because I can it
doesn't feel like cooperating does it
and yeah this is the YouTube app
basically all that makes your phone look
stock so if you're running sort of a
jellybean esque is it running stock
Android you can check out a whole bunch
of these apps in the Play Store from the
links below that's basically it so for
those of you who want see it on Twitter
happy holidays
glad you enjoyed what at least wanted to
see my setup to enjoy and hopefully this
will give you some ideas for your own
setup so thanks for watching and I'll
talk to you guys in the next video peace